Rico, listo. Listo, empezaremos la clase entonces. Me van a dar un...
que seman un pequeño momento, justamente, seguramente, de ambiente, de al escuchar un montón de ruidos,
así que si es que no se me escucha, porfa, me dicen, ya, pero voy a tratar de hacer claro.
El micrófono un poco más fuerte, justo, las máquinas están metiendo ruidos, así que era necesario, ya.
Eso, chicos, así que empezaremos la clase de hoy. Demócrita y voy a hacer el compartir.
Lo siguiente. Ya, antes de eso, les voy a mandar un formulario, por favor, dentro del cual al grupo lo voy a enviar inmediatamente.
Tratencíos y de llenarlo hasta el finalizar la clase para que yo envíe sus datos y demás a Embajada y de los asistentes también, ya.
Así que lo estoy enviando inmediatamente al grupo.
Solamente, por si acaso, traten de colocarlo todo en mayúsculas, ya.
Y, traten de colocar su nombre completo, ya que eso va a entrar a...
a cualquier certificación o control que les haga a Embajada o de programa mismo.
Así que esa parte, por favor, llenarlo con todo mayúsculas.
Ya solamente ese apellido completo, nombre, correo y su número de células, nada más.
¿Visto?
Esa parte, les voy a enviar ahorita mismo al grupo.
Para que puedan enlazar.
¿Listo?
Vayan en este caso mientras esperamos a sus compañeros respondiendo.
Por favor, llenarlo para que al finalizar la clase por ahí, de mismo les dé a mi asistencia.
Y, saque los screens de pantalla que me están pidiendo urgentemente de todos ustedes.
¿Listo? Así que aquí voy a colocar.
¿Listo?
Ya, eso vayan llenando hasta el finalizar la clase.
Lo empezaremos con la clase Chivocos.
Para lo cual, voy a abrir un navegador.
De un ratito.
Mmm, ya.
¿Listo?
Vayan, vayan llenando los que acaban de ingresar, por favor.
El formular y cuanto hayan llenado.
Miren hasta ahorita, pero vayan llenando.
Esperamos dos minutos más para empezar.
¿Listo? Porque falta no, pero son 14, falta todavía.
Y ya están dos, así que normal.
¿Ya?
Empezaremos.
Eh, voy a minimizar esto.
¿Listo?
Ya está, vamos a asegurar un poco.
Ahora empezaremos con sí.
Ya, empezaremos.
Vamos directamente a nuestro símbolo del sistema.
Ya, o CMD.
Hace un clic y inmediatamente, como ya tenía la tarea de haber instalado hasta el día de hoy.
Así que no se preocupen esa parte.
¿Cómo está?
Ya, empezaremos entonces.
¿Qué tal?
Me siento.
Solo terebironica.
Listo, y silenciado.
Ahora sí, continuaremos.
Entonces, para esta parte directamente, lo mismo chicocos, abran su documento Word.
Ya, lo mismo, van a colocar en este caso la misma disposición para el cual les alcance.
No sé si soy yo, se escucha muy bajo.
Hola, hola, no escuché?
Se escucha bien, ¿no?
Poco bajo, se escucha muy bajo.
Ya, a ver, voy a tratar de incrementar mi volumen.
Listo.
Listo, los damas me pueden confirmar, igual que si es problema mío, problema de su compañero,
si se escucha bastante lenta.
Listo, listo.
Si mi discurpo, se escucha en una empresa que está soldando y está en un lío, pero...
Voy a tratar de acercarme lo más que pueda.
Ya, deben escucharte, voy a acomodarme para que se escuche mejor.
Ya, ahora sí.
Lo mismo, chicos, voy a tratar de hablar fuerte para que me escuchen.
Hagan un stretch igual.
Clásico número dos.
Coloca en su nombre.
Tantos, tantos, tantos, tantos.
Y me van a hacer todo lo que les voy a indicar, porque día van a ser la primera tarea que no han hecho en eso,
pero que alcanzemos todo, pero lo esperemos que sí.
Y dentro de ahí, ya saben, coloque en clase número dos, nombre y voy a hacer lo siguiente, ya.
Aquí voy a colocar en este caso, diagramas.
Y workflows.
Listo.
Y eso lo concentrean y luego, inmediatamente, colocamos paso uno.
Ya.
Nada más.
Voy a avanzar de aquí algo de teoría para que me entiendan un poquito que es lo que voy a hablar.
Y posteriormente, vamos a empezar a diseñar ya.
Así que paso número uno, lo que vamos a hacer todos es abrir nuestro CMD
y verificar lo que son los siguientes diagramas, ¿no?
En este caso, voy a hacer...
Ya saben, en Note, voy a escribir lo minúsculo.
Y ahora, diómbra.
Ya.
Listo.
Una vez que tenga ahí instalado el Note, no es necesario colocar la parte Docker.
Todavía no vamos a empezar con Docker, pero si pueden instalarlo, si generalmente,
voy a instalar antes a las siguientes, sub siguientes clases,
no voy a avanzar todavía eso.
Hoy te voy a explicar algunos aspectos más de esto, ya.
Ahora, vamos a instalar directamente N8N.
Y ahora, voy a instalarla.
Pero la forma más común para instalarlo con Note es la siguiente,
NPX, para colocar N8N.
Listo.
Y apretan Enter.
Una vez que apretan Enter, les va a salir un montón de warnings.
Ya.
No van a ignorarlo porque esos warnings generalmente son porque a veces algunos archivos
o algunos segmentos dentro de N8N ya se han quedado depreven...
Digo, así ya no se aporta actualiza por la parte de la empresa, no es nuestra culpa,
es netamente de la empresa de N8N.
Así que hagan click y vamos a esperar porque esto va a tardar bastante.
Póngalo unos 10 minutos a 15 minutos.
Mientras yo voy a estar trabajando algo de teoría para que me entiendan.
Ya.
Pero así tarda.
Les va a parecer un montón de warnings, por si acaso.
Así que no se asusten, solamente esperaremos hasta que haga.
Por ejemplo, en el mío ya tengo N8N.
Como ya tengo por su meditación, estamos inicializando el proceso.
Cuando ustedes ya lo tengan, les va a decir lo mismo.
Ya.
Fíjense ahí, ya me he inicializado.
Y fíjense lo que me tiene que aparecer al último cuando ustedes se instalen toda la parte de N8N.
Deme un cachito, voy a admitirlo algunos más.
Ya.
Listo.
Ahí estoy instalando lo que son las licencias.
Demás tenemos ratito.
Listo.
Ahora sí.
Cuando ustedes han instalado de manera correcta, generalmente N8N trabaja en el loging.
En este caso en el link que se llama localhost.
Para todo lo que trabajemos dentro de nuestra de nuestra PC, o sea nuestra casa que es la PC,
siempre va a llamar, va a llamarse un localhost.
Ya.
Así que en ese aspecto, N8N corre en este link localhost 5678.
O si nos puede impresionar la letra o y les va a habilitar una una interfaz.
Ya.
A ver, apretan.
No se va a aparecer nada todavía.
A mí me va a aparecer seguramente.
Ya me está apareciendo.
Ahí está cargando.
Listo.
Por ejemplo, ya me voy a salir.
Ya.
Esto los tiene que aparecer.
Ya tienen que registrar sus tons.
Ya.
Así que hasta ahí les espero.
Veme un ratito.
Ya.
Seguramente les va a tardar bastante porque al principio siempre es así porque tardan
en instalarse todos los patrones, todas las licencias internas para lo que es la instalación
interna en su PC.
Así que en ese aspecto hay que esperar.
Listo.
Así que mientras tanto, si tienen algún problema, no se sustentan.
Siempre va a aparecer por warnings, por warnings.
Así que no, no, no se sustentan ese aspecto.
Una vez que generamos esa parte, voy a minimizar esto.
Voy a avanzar alito de teoría para que me entienda más o menos cómo voy a trabajar.
Se los voy a hacer.
Se los estoy haciendo aparte de una guía para que no tengan problemas al momento de empezar
al proceso de olvidarse algunos puntos.
Se los voy a hacer una guía.
Pero igual el video va a estar muy aparte en YouTube para que lo tengan de manera muy clara.
Listo.
Así que empezaremos directamente con algunos aspectos.
Voy a admitir a alguien más de Moncacho.
Ya.
Entonces me van a juntar en la parte de su Word, esta parte.
Que hayan ya creado todo esto y estén instalando el N8N.
Nada más.
Si es que les saliera error, me dicen mejor si no sale error.
Entonces si tenemos mayor cantidad de probabilidades de ser instalaciones.
No creo que les decían instalar la primera vez en Nout.
Cuando instalan varios Noutes hay que elegir la versión de Nout.
Pero como solamente la mayoría hemos instalado un Nout, así que no hay problema.
Ya una vez que hacemos eso voy a explicarles un cachito lo siguiente.
Excalidrado.
Ya les voy a explicar algunos aspectos.
Ya de mi cachito.
Ahora sí.
Voy a venirnos acá y les voy a explicar algunos puntos que vamos a tratar con esto.
A ver.
Lo siguiente.
Generalmente voy a trabajar con lo siguiente.
Voy a hacerlo así.
Y vamos a hacerlo lo siguiente.
Chicos.
Tata.
Ya me van a entender qué es lo que voy a generarme y cuáles son los procesos de autenticación y los procesos de manejo de, en este caso, N8N.
¿Listo?
Dentro de acá voy a colocar N8N.
N8N por si acaso.
Cuando trabajamos de manera...
Hay varias formas de trabajar N8N.
No solamente la que estamos utilizando, la forma local.
Hay N tipos.
Ya, dentro de los cuales, de mi cachito, voy a silenciar a algunas personas.
¿Listo?
Dentro de N8N, podemos trabajar de varias maneras.
No es de forma local la que estamos haciendo ahorita.
Así que de manera local,
estamos trabajando con Note.
Ya.
Esto es de manera local para mí.
Así que lo voy a adjuntar con un trazo para que se entienda qué les voy a explicar hoy día y qué más o menos vamos a trabajar en ese sentido.
Ya.
Así que de mancachito.
¿Listo?
Generalmente pasa lo siguiente.
A veces voy a copiar este pegar también.
De mancachito.
Ya.
Esto lo voy a acomodar.
Ya que la clase nos va a devorar con hora y media.
Así que vamos a tratar de avanzar.
Va a haber una clase o un mit o unos videos si es que tuvieran algún punto de errores durante la clase o demás.
Para que en este caso les pueda ayudar.
Porque en ese caso hay veces hay computadoras que son muy independientes de cada uno.
O sea, tienen diferente tipo de configuración en casos muy extremos ojo les digo.
Pero para ese tipo de caso sí o sí voy a tratar de hacer otro mit o directamente me pueden escribir a Limbox.
Ahí me responde la, siempre responde la noche por ese caso.
Listo.
Y otra forma por ese caso es Docker.
Ya.
Y vamos a bajar de manera local con note.
Esto netamente va a trabajar dentro de la PC.
Dentro de la PC.
Ya.
Lo que es la parte del Docker.
También trabajamos dentro de la PC.
Pero no solamente trabaja en nuestra PC como un contenedor.
Obviamente para esta parte nosotros tenemos que instalarnos lo que es Docker Desktop.
Ya vamos a instalar Docker Desktop.
Esto.
Visto.
Y esto para que me va a servir a futuro.
No solamente les comento que me sirve para contenerlo a un ánimo determinado versión de mi N8N.
Sino que aparte de trabajar de manera local en una PC, también nosotros podemos trabajar en producción.
Y donde se trabaja producción?
Pues en la nube.
Ya.
En la nube lo vamos a trabajar.
Entonces, pero estos dos ámbitos que les estoy mostrando tanto como es note como tantos Docker.
No sirven antes de empezar con la parte de producción o sea antes de comprarnos un servidor directamente de N8N o quizás de un servidor externo como AWS o también Hostinger.
También vende.
Hay otros que les voy a comentar que le voy a contar a vos.
También ahí es.
Y van a ver que los costos que me ofrecen son de diferente característica y diferentes tipos de peticiones.
Ahorita os voy a mostrar cómo vamos a trabajar acá.
Y luego obviamente tenemos cuando ya adquirimos un servidor.
Este servidor es para mi el VPS.
Ya.
Yo les recomiendo si ya son programadores o ya desarrollan sistemas más avanzados.
Pues trabajar directamente con VPS sería adecuado para empresas que ya son gigantes y necesitan netamente una seguridad informática bastante avanzada.
Entonces así pues normal se trabaja con VPS.
Ya esto obviamente también es un tipo de producción.
O sea cuando yo digo producción ya está trabajando en la nube.
Ya puede ver el usuario.
Ya tiene interacción con el cliente, con nuestros proyectos, etcétera.
Eso significa cuando ya hablo de producción.
Ya.
Ya esta parte por si acaso a veces es complicadito.
¿Por qué razones?
Porque cuando trabajo con VPS generalmente se lo extiende en ambiente Linux.
Seguramente los que estamos así de cero digamos en la clase les voy a explicar un poquito de esto.
Generalmente se han escuchado ahí Windows.
Ahí en este caso tenemos operativos Windows, Mac y Linux.
Ya.
Ya hay un cuarto más.
Pero en este caso los tres más conocidos.
Y obviamente este tipo de servidores para tener una calidad de información y que no puedan banearnos, hackearnos, etcétera.
Siempre es de la manera mucho más eficiente extenderla por Linux.
Ya.
Y esto se hace con generalmente con todas las VPS, no solamente con la N8N.
Hay lo que es un AutoMatch en Proyection, lo que es con la ARABEL y también se hace para los que dominan esa parte de programación.
Pero esta parte sí o sí es necesario que nos compremos un dominio.
¿A qué me refiero dominio?
Dominio me refiero cuando hay estas cositas.
El punto com digamos no sé se llama mi tienda epito punto como manualidades punto o erigido punto net no sé el nombre que ustedes siempre entran a una determinada web o sistema.
Siempre les da eso.
Eso para mí es un dominio.
Ahora parte de que nosotros tenemos que comparar un dominio.
La parte más compleja por eso es que es todo más dedicado a empresas un poquito más serias y que necesiten una alta resolución en su sistema de.
Testin así que en esa parte es mejor para ellos y obviamente un servidor.
VPS eso es necesario.
Ahora vámonos al cuarto.
Ahora ustedes pueden trabajar sin hacer esto.
Este es una.
Esto es un dolor de cabeza para no complicarse la vida.
Lo más fácil directamente decirle a n 8 n vendeme lo que tú tu ofreces y generalmente lo que es las casas n 8 n.
Punto cloud.
Eso es a que les va a vender.
O sea, es la versión original de n n 8 m la que estamos descargando ahí me ofrece.
Ya.
Y hay otro en este caso que va a ser el siguiente.
Entonces explicar algunas características de cada uno de manera un poco más global.
Ya dentro de acá por ejemplo y ahí lo que son servidores externos.
También se lo llama de terceros.
Uno de los más conocidos en este caso puede ser a bw s puede ser a sure puede ser en este caso host inga.
Pero hay montón de empresas que me ofrecen servicios externos o de terceros.
Ya que me refiero con eso juegan como un intermediario con n 8 n y me ofrece bastante calidad al momento de procesar y o sea lo vuelve bastante fácil.
O sea con un click ya tienen su proceso.
Pero siempre lo más adecuado y lo más elo cuente siempre se empieza por este o por este para no tener problemas a la larga.
Y luego no que no nos entendamos o que cuando ya tengamos una en producción obviamente es más fácil.
Pero siempre es bueno ya trabajar sin pagar mientras tanto.
Ya.
Entonces viendo eso esta parte por ejemplo se los voy a notar acá a n 8 n punto cloud.
También se le conoce como en enterprise enterprise ahorita os explicar por qué.
Les explico ahora de manera general haciendo un resumen rápidamente mientras que haya ya de estar en este caso terminando sin instalación.
Así que os voy a dar unos supongo cinco minutos más para ver si los está corriendo.
Ya déme un ratito chico que cosa está ahí.
Ya entonces explico rápidamente.
Vamos a hacer un resumen de manera mucho más detallada porque esto pasa de parte también de su evaluación.
Cuando ya presenta en sus proyectos así que siempre es necesario saber lo que hace porque hace como lo hace.
Ya.
Bueno, os repartíos.
Note me ejecuta n 8 n directamente con no gs.
Dentamente en nuestra computadora.
Para qué lo utilizamos para aprender a hacer pruebas, crear automatizaciones básicas y de desarrollo local y avanzado.
O sea se puede hacer.
Cuales son las ventajas que obviamente es fácil de instalar hemos visto que solamente hemos estado en la Ud.
Y listo.
Pero que es lo malo.
Hay veces se detiene si apagamos la pese por ese caso.
Ya.
Porque siempre hay que inicializarlo antes de iniciar un proyecto.
Esto es netamente para estudios para estudiantes.
En este caso nuestros propios emprendimientos, nuestros propios negocios para eso me sirve más que todo.
Docker es lo mismo casi.
Solamente que dentro de Docker nos exige un poquito más a la con puedes decir.
No se exige un ram.
Nos exige un poquito en nuestras características internas.
Y eso.
Además me ofrece un desarrollo más limpio y obviamente es portable.
Eso es lo bueno de Docker.
Por eso vamos a ver también el módulo.
Ahora esta parte de servidores VPS también se instala Docker les comento pero de una nube.
O sea cuando adquirimos pagamos lo instalamos también Docker ahí.
Y podemos tener el sistema funcionando 24 7.
Ya.
Lo bueno es que de esto las ventajas son producción real, accesor remoto es escalable y además son compatibles con diferentes dominios y SSL.
O sea protección externa.
Ya.
Lo malo tiene un costo mensual.
Además requiere Linux y algunas algunas conocimientos en redes para que lo puedan hacer con VPS.
Ya.
Dónde se lo utiliza.
Eso también quiero que lo entiendan.
Generalmente cuando adquirimos VPS se los utilicen empresas industriales en empresas que tienen grande cantidad de usuarios y además para bots.
O sea si ya le podemos aumentar automatizaciones industriales incluso.
Ya.
Ahora lo que es el siguiente n8n cloud.
Es mucho más así porque.
No también te tiene el servicio oficial de n8n.
Además usamos n8n sin instalar nada en su sistema.
Y en este caso de Moncayito.
Las actualizaciones ya van por defecto.
O sea no tienen que estar actualizando son automáticos y además tiene seguridad integrada.
Lo malo que también es de pago y tiene menor control técnico más que todo.
Ahora el último servidor es externos o de terceros.
Aquí si se instala n8n pero en la nube.
Ya sea con a bwc o amazon web service google cloud o microsoft azure que son los tres más comunes.
Aquí se se lo hace una arquitectura más que todo empresarial o escalable o sea si quieres agrandar sigue tu sistema para automatizar lo puedes hacer no hay problema.
Y además son muy potentes estos servidores porque tiene.
Arta disponibilidad en una integración más o menos empresarial.
Lo malo que a veces puede ser más costoso que el mismo n8n pero ahorita os voy a mostrar algunos que pueden trabajar ustedes.
Uno muy aparte de estos voy a admitir a alguien más de Moncayito.
A ver a ver quién está acá.
Ya uno más interesante.
Y lo podemos trabajar y van a ver que funciona bastante bien.
Vamos a trabajar con un sistema un poquito más interesante se llama.
Cloud for Tunel.
Qué es el Cloud for Tunel así que aquí los voy a colocar.
Ya vamos a venir acá perdón perdón perdón.
Listo aquí voy a enserrarme estos dos.
Voy a pintarlo de otro colorcito.
Ya y voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Dentro de acá por ejemplo papá saló siguiente.
Hay uno que se llama les vuelvo a repetir se llama.
Cloud.
Flurn.
Tunel.
Ya.
Cloud for Tunel en este caso me sirve se los voy a notar por acá.
Ya voy a cambiar de colorcito.
Me sirve.
Ay perdón perdón perdón me sirve.
Para que una app o sea una aplicación un software cualquier cosa o sistema sobre todo sistema.
Que.
Que esté nuestra computadora.
Ya en este caso.
Puede ser visto.
Desde internet.
Ya.
Mediante una.
UR.
Y ahorita vamos a la prueba es como funciona y van a ver cómo los voy a tomar video asistencia con eso.
Ya.
A qué me refiero con esto.
Este sistema.
Es como un reemplazo a lo siguiente voy a venir acá voy a venirme acá.
Voy a pintar el estituidad.
Es como una.
Opción a este.
Ya.
Es como una opción.
Así lo voy a llevar.
Misto.
Porque.
Es fácil de manipular.
No te cobra dinero.
Y además mi computadora puede funcionar normalmente dentro de mi computadora local.
O sea dentro de mi red porque no estoy conectada nada.
Le envío un túnel.
Ese túnel lo encripto o le mando unas se llama en este caso una sub capa.
Lo envío a mis usuarios o lo puedo camuflar a un usuario.
Y eso se puede ver sin que yo pague ningún tipo de dinero en un dominio externo.
Se puede hacer con.
Por ejemplo no sé.
Si trabajamos ahorita por ejemplo si estamos viendo acá en el enero 8 en aquí está instalándose.
Si nos damos cuenta este su URL.
Esto trabaja en mi PC o sea de manera local no va a funcionar en otro lugar más solamente en mi PC y para mi PC.
Ya cuando yo le aplico CloudFront.
Esto lo puedo camuflar y en vez de que diga 5678 le puedo decir mi negocio.com o no.
No sé empresas de calzados perlita.com o sea le puedo camuflar y eso le envío a mi cliente.
Y el normal puede pedir mis pedidos sin que yo tenga que pagar tengo que tengo tengo que pagar dominios.
Lo malo que mi PC si es que estoy haciendo algún tipo de escalabilidad o toma de datos.
Por ejemplo si el usuario tiene que subir videos y no sé un montón de archivos pesados.
No es conveniente porque mi computadora va a sufrir.
Ya porque necesitamos mayor cantidad de memoria pero no hay problema.
Creo que la mayoría solamente requiere datos, parámetros, quizás cueres, quizás pagos bancarios, etc.
Así se puede hacer con esto.
Ya por ejemplo nosotros trabajamos ahorita para el Banco Unión.
Yo hago sus sistemas de enlazado para que replaciones a otros países así que normal se puede hacer con eso.
Ya otro.
En base a eso ya podemos trabajar con Crawford.
Y hay otro que los voy a hoy día hacer pruebas si es que lo quieren.
Obviamente no es el objetivo de la materia en señales quizás sistemas de encriptación avanzada porque si es que va a haber un módulo 2
ahí si los podría dar un poquito más de contexto porque va a ser un poquito complicado.
En Charmarmonte programas hay aquí esta clase.
No es una clase de automatización, pero si quieren les enseño no hay problema con otro que les puedo hacer mucho más corto.
Entonces eso es para mí un resumen netamente de lo que es N8n y de lo que vamos a ver.
Ya ahora sí.
Espero que ya de todos esté instalado.
Pueden hacer lo siguiente.
Si quieren ahí control se o pueden apretar la letra o les había comentado y se va a abrir lo que es su sistema.
O sea esto tal cual si es que no hayan registrado nada no tienen usuarios va a pedir registro.
Hay coloquen en e-mail que se que tienen y coloquen un password que no se puedan olvidar a no ten se.
Y luego van a estar cambiándolos y que ahorita se cómo se cambia los usuarios por una interfaz y no hay problema.
Pero hasta ahí les espero una vez que lleguen acá igual.
Sacan su capturita que diga con este local host ahí.
Y lo van a adjuntar a su documento.
Ya paso dos van a colocar.
Compilando van a desecompilar.
Y listo.
Para que no les sea muy feo porque esta imagen se hizo muy grande.
Después de minimizarlo y tratan de enviarme en tamaño legal y a tamaño oficio.
Para que les vaya alcanzando acá.
Más ordenado su proyecto.
Ya vamos a irnos al paso tres.
Hasta ahí les espero si necesitan un poquito más de tiempo para que no les pisa.
Mientras tanto de un minutito creo que mi máquina se va a buguear.
Hasta ahí los chicos que os vayan adjunto a eso.
Mientras tanto voy a declarar igual la parte de clasroom para que vayan inicializando.
No se preocupen, va de ese montón de warnings.
Una vez que han colocado y se ha instalado.
Pueden abrir o te aterminan.
Vienen acá, pueden colocar.
En este caso pueden cerrarlo.
Si les ha dejado ahí bien instalado.
O sea los cierran y lo vuelven a abrir.
Otro entorno.
Para que se acabe acá para empezar con n8n.
O sea para activarlo para ponerlo en marcha.
Solamente coloquen n8n.
Así de minúscula.
N8n.
Otra forma es la que les he dicho.
Si no les funciona ese pueden colocar npmn8n.
Si no les funciona colocan n8n start.
Cualquiera de los tres les va a dar.
Listo.
Hasta hoy les espero chicos.
Yo lo voy a cerrar.
Con ustedes voy a iniciar.
Lo voy a volver a cerrar esto.
Voy a abrir de nuevo.
Voy a cerrar lo mi antiguo comando.
Y aquí.
A ver, coloquen n8n start.
Si no les funciona ya saben los demás.
No me reconozca a mi por ejemplo.
Si colocan n8n tampoco.
Pero ya saben que hacer.
npmn8n.
Con eso funciona de mi.
De otros puede funcionar con otro.
De mi hasta por ejemplo corriendo.
Así que en esa parte podemos hacer eso.
Nada más.
Listo.
Yo los espero chicos mientras voy a estar.
Copiándose los todito acá.
Si no les funciona.
Si no te funciona tampoco van a colocar npmn8n.
Es otra cuarta forma.
¿Qué pasó?
Es Ricardo.
¿Más o menos 430 en la aplicación de n8n?
Más o menos te diría unos 85 a 100 ms.
No es tan pesada.
No, no es pesadamente tarde en instalarse.
Ese es el punto.
Ya.
Así que normal.
Yo sigo aquí en el cmd.
Y creo que sigue todavía.
No te preocupes.
Se tiene que votar.
No son eso.
Si les vota.
Normal.
Vayan esperando.
Siempre tarde al principio.
Es un lío.
Así que no se preocupen.
Ya.
Listo.
Por si acaso esto también.
Si tiene una computadora menos de 4 de RAM.
Igual funciona.
Solamente va a ser obviamente más lento.
Mientras sus RAM sea 16.
Eso detecta el n8n.
Y va a ser más veloz.
Pero eso depende mucho.
Ya.
Así que los espero.
Los doy unos 5 minutitos.
Así que empezamos luego con la otra fase.
Ya.
Listo.
Y ahorita os voy a decir qué van a instalarse para hacer un VPS.
Si es que quieren aprender zapartas.
Interesante.
Incluso sirve para hackear sistemas de sus propios compañeros.
Yo hackeo por ejemplo WhatsApp con eso.
Para sistemas de.
De que hay personas que veces hacen no sé.
Marañas para robar digamos de las cárceles.
Nosotros les valeamos y les.
Les generamos un boot para que se destruyan todos.
Solar es alternos con eso.
Si.
Cuál es tu consulta.
Hola.
Puede hablar más.
O me bogeo yo.
Sin más.
Escuchemos.
Y listo.
No.
Ya.
Ahora sí.
Mi disculpas estoy medio que.
Mi sistema está medio bogeado.
Yo.
Dina.
Hola, hola, hola, ahora sí. Ya, ¿me escuchan, no? Eh, soy, soy, estoy ahorita con un montón
de micrófonos y se me buguean los micrófonos. Ya, sí, normal, volvete a crear tu nueva
cuenta. Ya que esto es de manera local, o sea, no te va a detectar en el 8 en la parte
del internet y cualquier tipo de flujos que manejas fuera de tu PC. Así que normal, creense
de nuevo, si es que les pides. Ya, pero igual, anotense y no se olviden el usuario ni el
contraseño. Ya, ingresen y ahorita empezamos con la segunda parte. Visto. ¿Se me escuchan,
no chico? Cosa creo que sí. Por favor, te voy a cambiar de micro y estoy un lío acá.
Ya, no sé qué me voy a hacer. No escucho. ¿Mildisculpa? Sí. Hace ratos, te lo escuchaba
mal, cuando estaba hablando sobre el VPS, podría repetir lo que había dicho antes. Super,
super, super. Ya. Para, a modo de que les voy a dejar dando un poquito más de tiempo,
ya. Así que, vuelvas a repetir. Lo que son estos dos entornos tanto Note y Docker, lo trabajamos
de manera local. Ya, obviamente con Note es mucho más fácil hacer una proceso de no 8n para
aprender cómo funciona, hacer mis workflows, automatizarlo para mi negocio, etcétera. A no,
a no, a no un nivel mucho, muy magno como una empresa, digamos estatal o privada. Ya,
Docker también se trabaja de manera local, pero lo bueno de Docker, si cuando aprendemos
a manejar Docker, ya podemos manejar de manera mucho más sencilla y mucho más fácil, lo que es
VPS. VPS es más dedicado a ambientes donde las empresas requieren una mayor calidad de información,
mayor versatilidad y además seguridad informática. Esto generalmente lo hacen las empresas
industriales o las empresas de orden agrario, de orden que manejan flujos económicos de
dinero bastante fuertes se lo hace. Por ejemplo, la cualquier banco maneja VPS y sus VPS pueden
generarse contenedores para hacer, por ejemplo, si yo un cliente mando mi cuere, ya de pago para
una pasarela de pago, llega al banco, el banco me notifica, me manda un cheque y me manda lo que es
un mensajito que ven ustedes, que me dice, ay, tu tu abono ha sido correcto, etcétera. Para esas
cositas me sirven VPS y no solamente en este campo, en varios campos como el IoT para programaciones
avanzadas, me sirven. Lo malo que es, hay veces en el instalo bajo el entorno Linux, ya sea de manera
local o de manera en la nube, ya también se llama producción. En esa parte, por eso un poquito
complicado esto, ¿ya? ¿Qué hago yo? Generalmente lo más fácil es comprar una, bueno, un servidor
netamente de n8n, quiero, tiene todo, o sea, con un cliente ya estás automatizando todo y obviamente
servidores externos, que es otra parte, otro punto también de cómo puede funcionar n8n, ya esa parte.
Ahora, dentro de los VPSes, hay bastantes tipos de aplicaciones, por ejemplo, si ahorita estoy en mi
computadora, ¿ya? Estamos haciendo un estuentorno local. Si quiero que mi entorno local se automatice
y lo pueda ver otro usuario, otro cliente, puedo crearme yo un CloudFortunnel. CloudFortunnel
crea un túnel, ese túnel, aunque yo no haya comprado un dominio, un servidor, esto lo trabaja de manera
gratuita y lo gamufla o le hace una máscara. Si mi ahorita fíjense acá, cuando ya he activado en
este caso, me he hecho en acuando ya, he instalado, me bota lo que es el localhost 5678, esto es para
mí mí, lojin o mí. En este caso, mi entorno del lugar para acceder, ¿ya? Es mi localhost. Esto
yo lo voy a, en vez de esto, lo voy a camuflar y voy a hacer que se llame pepito.com o ventadecarsados.com.
Eso lo voy a enviar a mi cliente y por eso enlaces va a echar, pero no va a conocer cómo estoy
trabajando yo. Eso se hace con CloudFortunnel, o sea, es un creador de VPSes, en este caso para
sistemas locales, no hay problema. Que es lo malo, a veces puede ser peligroso si es que manejo
flujos de dinero o flujos que realmente son importantes, no solamente dinero. ¿Ya? Por eso...
CloudFortunnel, la idea de que yo soy un seguro, pero que pueda hackear un link,
yo comparto posto de.patre. Exacto, se, se puede hackear. Por eso es que quizás para entornos
mucho más básicos o sencillos de automatizar, no hay problema, pero si son cosas un poquito
importantes, no es bueno. Si eso sería contratar un servicio en la Noda.
Ya, eso. Ahora voy a hacer un ejemplo de eso. Con eso voy a tratar de ensargar a sus computadoras
hoy día y desde ahí vamos a ver qué tan... si le dan permiso, pero voy a tratar de enviar
si no es algún tipo de mensajes hoy. Ya, así que empezaremos. Ya, ahora chicos, antes que nos
pise el tiempo, porque ya enviamos 45 minutos y empezaremos con la segunda fase. Ya, una vez
que hayan hecho esto, pueden copiar esto, Ctrl C, Ctrl B y directamente pueden enlaces acá.
Ya y les va a aparecer lo que se lo yo. Ahí se registran y normal. Ya, en mi caso ya lo tengo
registrado. Así que voy a loguearme. Si es que me acuerdo mi control señal.
Visto. Ya no me acuerdo de esta cuenta. Ah, voy a recordarme un fechito.
Listo, ya está. Les debería aparecer esto. Ya. Entonces, este es el entorno de N8N.
Si. Alguien quiere hablar creo. Cuando me te logro me aparece el problema si tengo readouts.
Ya verificas si tu contraseña y usted está bien o si no, a veces ocurre lo que tú me dices
cuando no se inicia esto. O sea, esto lo tienes que cerrar y volver a abrir cuando ya hayas
instalado nuevamente y decían abrilo esto. No directamente te voy a generar problemas. Ya.
A ver, intenta eso. Si no te da, me dices para que compartas pantalla. Ya. Mientras tanto.
A los que acaban de entrar, si son problemas muy complejos y nos demore toda una clase,
voy a tratarme de conectar nuevamente un mit fuera de la clase. Lo solucionamos,
ya semos todo eso. Por su caso, para que no se pierdan, como se está grabando la clase,
aparte te voy a pasar una guía. Esa guía tiene todo paso, paso, paso para que no se pierdan,
pero igual va a estar otros videos más. Así que no se preocupen. Siempre voy a tratar pendientes
y nos escriben directamente a Limboxes que no pueden o tienen algún problema. ¿Listo? No hay problema.
Este es el entorno de N8n. Pueden ir a settings y aquí pueden ver un montón de cosas. Hay N8n,
APIs, iLogin, hay un montón de cosas. Pueden cambiar incluso sus usuarios personales. Aquí,
por ejemplo, si entran acá, pueden cambiar en este caso sus passwords. Ya si es que se han olvidado,
o si es que están poniendo cualquier tipo de passwords, pueden cambiarlo ahí. Ya, pero esta
interfaz no me interesa mucho porque no vamos a trabajarlo todavía. ¿Qué pasó, Bayman?
Bueno, quería hacer una consulta a los usuarios que comentó hace rato. Era sobre, específicamente,
ya que ahorita está en un local post, en N8n. Es más seguro manejarlo desde el local post. No tiene
menos posibilidades de lo que está diciendo. Y lo que comentó Bermas, además de los trucos,
si les acudes que vayamos a evitar tenerla en la nube, ¿no? Y consultarle, ¿tendríamos que
tener servidores específicos? ¿Te puede decir como tener computadores específicos para manejar
todo el sistema de nuestra tema? No, no, porque incluso con una máquina que es de memoria,
no sé, 4 de RAM, por lo que, normal trabaja. O sea, solamente son más lentas. La parte de que
me exija más cosas, tener más cosas, mucho va a depender de qué quieres hacerlo. Por ejemplo,
7, 8n le quieres colocar agentes de ella. ¿Sabes que te va a consumir un montón de memoria, GPUs,
etcétera? Ahí sí sería una computadora mínimo de 16 gigas. Pero servidores, servidores, no,
porque tú mismo el computador lleva a ser un servidor y ya te actúa como servidor ahorita.
Pero si vas a ser, no sé, autométese tu negocio o generar clientes, sobre cuál son tus
estadísticas de cliente promocional por tu sistema normal, soporta, no hay problemas.
Solamente que mientras más bajo sea tu, el GPU, la RAM de tu compu, obviamente va a demorar un
poquito más, pero igual va a funcionar. Porque la parte de encryptación, seguridad,
todo eso se lo coloca más que todo en la parte de los links. No se lo coloca dentro de la compu o
dentro de tu mismo servidor interno. Así que de ese aspecto no te preocupes. Ahora, de manera local,
sí es un poco más seguro, pero también hay que tener un conocimiento de criptografía para evitar
cosas un poco más complejas. Ahora, lo bueno de la Nube, si adquirimos de las empresas que les comenté,
y ahorita les voy a mostrar unas tres más que son bastante asequibles hablando en temas de dinero,
van a ver que sí ofrece bastante seguridad. Porque ellos incluso te ofrecen, si es que te
banean, te van a desestablecer, incluso te dan indemnización. Así que de esa parte,
ambos casos son buenos. Solamente algunos tienen ventajas y desventajas, depende mucho del sistema
que queremos revisar. Ok.
Listo, Vime. ¿Qué más?
Oresín.
Sobre esa cometerna, lo último que voy a preguntar, la verdad me gustó mucho lo que nos
explica ahorita en la posibilidad, porque era el tema del tigerma, la teoría, el tema del
informecer, todo el no-how que vamos a tener de la empresa, el confluto. Así que va a ser importante.
Y quería hacer una pregunta, si conoce específicamente en Bolivia. No sé si las empresas que me
nombró eran exteriores o las que nombró, porque específicamente Bolivia también para saber
dónde está nuestra información, dónde está nuestra, nuestro flujo y todo eso. Porque lo que pasa es
que, te comento Milton, había un programa de cooperación internacional. Lo voy a contar así
con uno pequeño. Lo que nos comentaron era que había un programa de cooperación internacional,
que no sabían, o sea que los servidores y la nube de toda la actividad que se hizo en la
cooperación internacional para ayudar a las personas, todo la información estaba en otro lugar.
Y apenas si fue la cooperación internacional, todo eso se lo llevó la, pero todo lo que había
trabajado se quedó sin nada. Así que quería saber, yo, yo, en lo personal quisiera eso,
tener servidor específico y saber dónde está el servidor para cuidar todo eso.
Listo. Bueno, te explico ahora ese detallamento un poquito para el conocimiento general, digamos.
Bueno, los servidores o datacenters que manejan un montón de cosas o flujos de combinaciones,
la mayoría se encuentra en tres países claros, Argentina, Brasil y Colombia. Ya son esos tres
países que tienen datacenters en nivel Mac, no tanto de Google, tanto de web service de Tesla,
de lo más neurolinx, etcétera. Tienen ahí. Ahora, lamentablemente, Bolivia, en ese aspecto,
si está retrasado, no tenemos datacenters, así de gran escala. Una de las mayores potencias
que tenemos como país es que desayunamos software y lo vendemos a Estados Unidos. O sea, por ejemplo,
el software que hacen los cochabambinos es la de la empresa Alpharn. Alpharn se llama. El software
está trabajando ahorita con el MIT. El MIT y parte de IBM. Ellos les respaldan y hacen sus
softwares. Pero y además tienen un servidor más o menos de tres terabytes, más o menos por orden
de clips que tienen. Cuchabamba. Ya si van a su... Está por tiki pay ahorita esa empresa. Si van a
visitar Super, les voy a tratar de enviar ubicaciones exactas si es que me dicen que les pase, pero
ahí está. Todos los flujos de dato, lamentablemente, se centralizan a Estados Unidos y se centralizan en
Europa. Las mentirías y les digo que se centraliza el servidor de la nube y todos los flujos. Son
hallazos centrales. Tienen obviamente sus subcentrales en Latinoamérica, en cualquier parte del mundo
lo tienen. Pero a esa escala solamente la tiene los países desarrollados. En Sudamérica, Brasil,
Perú y Argentina tienen las tres grandes. Porque en Perú, por ejemplo, la Changai, donde ya va a
estar el puerto de la NASA, ahí va a estar trabajando en datacente. Y ahora, si se han dado cuenta,
van a instalar aquí dos datacentes en la paz. Ya y también se va a tener... Ahora, al momento de irse
a una cooperación, sí, una cooperación es cuando tienen un limitante de tiempo. O sea, si la cooperación
termina, todos se lo llevan. Por eso se llama cooperación. Co-O, o sea, trabajo de ambos. Es
cooperativo. Si uno se va, pues, si es de él, pues se lo llevan. Y la única forma de que nosotros
desarrollemos tecnología avanzada es que sí o sí generemos no solamente software, sino hardware
y que tengamos las infraestructuras necesarias que necesitastas. Por ejemplo, si o si un datacente
y un servidor así de gran potencia, tiene que trabajar en lugares donde es frío. Sí o sí,
porque hay un montón de probabilidades que ocurren un montón de... No se ha escuchado,
¿no? Ya lo que estaba hace unos meses, un bon que se va a acabar el agua, que necesitamos que
cualquier servidor necesita agua y un datacente necesita... Sí, es verdad, porque para refrigar
a esos sistemas, sí se necesita eso. No es mentir, no es tanto, tanto mentira lo que han dicho. No sé,
sí es verdad. Ahorita los bancos de acá trabajan con los datacentres de Argentina. Ahí se envían
los datos. Y de Argentina se los envía por fibra óptica y por Océano, a Estados Unidos y
veían desde los sataníteles también. O sea, es un mundo la ingeniería de redes. ¿Listo? Eso. Pero
sí se... Sí, lamentablemente todas las entradas están ahí. Por ejemplo, ahorita les voy a mostrar
de Hostinger. Hostinger, la mayor lo conoce, pero Hostinger con N8N, por ejemplo. Me ofrece ya
un sistema autolojado. Es el que es más barato, se podría decir. Mira, ahorita está con el 69%
de descuantos y... Da, ahorita les voy a mostrar varias publicidades para que no sea unitaria.
¡Ay, Hostinger! Lo pueden comprar. O pueden comprar también Contabo. Pero Contabo es bastante...
¿Vas barato? Mira. Ya. Ahí está. Ay, Dios, aquí está. Contabo.
Listo. A ver si entramos a Contabo. Por ejemplo, esto para mí es un servidor de terceros. Si se dan
cuenta, está ahorita 4.50. 3.60 en el N8N mensual. O sea, es barato. Es baratísimo. Porque si entramos a
N8N Cloud, si entramos a N8N Cloud... Es exacto. A ver, voy a... ¿Escucho muy bajito o es mi impresión?
A ver. Listo. Ah, ya. Listo, listo. Entonces, por ejemplo, acá, por ejemplo, si van a pricing,
van a ver que es un poco más caro la N8N. Mira, 20 dólares en el N8N. Eso trabaja con NCloud. Pero
fíjense, ahorita vamos a hablar de workflows. Workflows se llama en tener lugar de trabajo. Es decir,
cuántas conexiones puedo realizar de manera macnasa se llama un workflow. Por ejemplo,
aquí a 20 dólares me ofrece, miren, 50 AIs workflow with credits. Si trabajamos con las 50
dólares, miren, sube 150. Y va a diferentes tipos de escalas, pero obviamente es más car. Mira,
800 dólares mensuales, esto la pagan las empresas grandes. Pero fíjense, pero este monto comparado
con este. Prefiero comprarme este, ¿no? Una vez que aquí aprendan lo básico, lo necesario,
un poco lo intermedio, ya pueden empezar con este. Porque si ofrece buena adaptabilidad,
tiene seguridad, la mayoría lo hace acá. Trabaja con esto. Incluso les puedo comentar que nosotros
trabajamos con para nuestros clientes con el N8N se los hacemos. Y esto hacen ellos. Se los
compramos y pagan montos un momento bajos para hacerlos. Pero si quieren una versión un poquito
más estándar, mayor cantidad de APIs, porque a veces las APIs hay que pagarlas. Mientras que cuando
la compran de acá, de N8N y directo, tiene ventajas. Por ejemplo, si nos vamos a docs y vamos a
documentation, vamos a irnos acá. Van a ver qué ventajas me da y qué desventajas puede darme
también. Ya voy a irme. ¿Me han detectado un malware? Por ejemplo, así integraciones me
interesa a mí. Voy a trabajar con diferentes que esto, creencia, creencia. Esto es la parábita
clave. Miren, HTTP. Sé que la mayoría no es del ámbito de programación, pero si entienden lo que es
un HTTP, hacen lo que quieran. Ese es el punto. Y no solamente incluso en la sala con cosas
automatizadas normales o naturales o comunes. Esto lo pueden enlazar con su Alexa. Lo pueden enlazar
con visión artificial, con cámaras. A eso mundo cuando empezamos a nacer HTTPS, MQTT,
STCPIPS, M-MOD, RTU, MOD, BOS, STCPIPE, hay un montón de protocolos que ellos trabajan
en el hardware y software. Si queremos automatizar ya con visiones artificiales, automáticos,
electrónicas, etcétera, etcétera, se hace con eso. Y eso es lo bueno, porque esto me ofrece a 20
dobles de los aspectos. Por ejemplo, el teleflico de la PAS trabaja con esto para generar sus flujos
directos. Ya, eso. Ahora sí, vámonos a... Ya, una vez que ya lo tienen, si no hay más preguntas,
continuamos. Ya, voy a continuar. Ya, una vez que hemos venido acá, vámonos a irnos directamente
acá. Ya, empezaremos con la primera práctica. Una vez que ya han tenido esto, pueden echarse
Great Warflow. Y les va a parecer estar esta interfaz. Ya, esta interfaz no tengan miedo. O
sea, no esperen a que tengamos sido así la clase. Vayan averiguando. Vayan viendo para que
sirve cada botoncito. Vayan en este caso, quemándolo, destruyendo, combinando, cualquier cosa. Porque
es la única forma de aprender. No va a pasar nada. Ya. Así que pueden ver cómo funciona esto,
si es esto, cómo funciona esto, para que me sirve esto, acercarse, venir, ver qué son templates,
insights, etcétera, etcétera. Siempre sean curiosos. Ya, démenme un momento, un minutito,
chicos. Déjenme un pechito, por favor. Ya, ahora sí, saliremos. Mil disculpas, mil disculpas. Tengo
perritos y sentan como locos. Así que, sorry, sorry. Ya, ahora sí. Ya, empezaremos con la primera
práctica. Aquí atrás, si van a la parte derecha superior, hay un más. Ya, si hacemos click ahí,
hay bastantes opciones que les voy a explicar uno a uno cómo funciona. Y luego les voy a explicar
cómo vamos a hacerlo de manera legal. Ya. Lo voy a borrar esto. Lo voy a ensar acá. Y vamos a entender
para qué sirve, por qué lo hago, cuándo se trabaja, cuándo no, etcétera, etcétera. Ya.
Generalmente, todo acá son triggers. Los triggers son actuadores. Un actuador, ¿qué entendemos por
un actuador? Es un motor. O lo que hace o lo que realiza. En base a qué? En base a una petición.
Estos términos quizás se van a ser desentendidos, pero yo lo digo get y post. El get es cuando
quiero enviar una información y el post es cuando yo recibo una información. Ya, o cuando recibo una
respuesta. Eso, get y post. Eso, eso, memorizarse. Ya. Un trigger, entonces, para mí es una ejecución
del flujo de manera manual. Eso para esto me sirve. Pero para qué me sirve esto? Ejecuta el sistema
manualmente. O sea, mediante un click, mediante una botonía. Eso es el trigger. Ya. En este caso,
por ejemplo, para probar si un bot o para depurar errores, puedo utilizar un trigger. Ya. El otro,
one up events. En este caso, esto me sirve para activar generalmente flujos cuando algo
ocurre en otra aplicación, en una app, por ejemplo, en Telegram. Si hay algún click, me tiene que
enviar en 8N y en el ancho, me tienen que procesar. Para eso me sirve esto. Ya. También se lleva,
por ejemplo, otro ejemplo, digamos, por WhatsApp o Telegram. Cuando me llegue un mensaje, este sistema
lo puede guardar en un Google Sheets o me puede enviar un mensaje a mi Gmail. Pónganle. Puede
poder trabajar de esa manera. El one is car. En este caso, ejecuta automáticamente por tiempo. Y
esto es bien importante. El one is car. Porque este me dice, por ejemplo, no sé, yo he tenido
ventas desde las seis de la mañana, las 8 de la mañana hasta las 6 de la tarde. Ya. Y quiero yo que
cada vez que termine el día o las ventas, póngales a las 9 de la noche, quiero que me envíe un mensaje
de todo el ingreso, todo el ingreso que he tenido o cuántos clientes he tenido. En este, este trigger
se encarga de decirme y acordarme. Eso es como un alarma que ya está programado para el día,
hora, fecha o si quieren cada día. Eso es el, el scar. Ya ahora el siguiente. El web hook.
Esto es uno de los más mortales. Les diría porque el web es. Es el trinco más utilizado,
porque no solamente trabajamos con sistematizaciones automáticas. Aquí ya se puede hacer virtualizaciones
y visión artificial y control de cámaras, control de servidores, control de lo que ustedes
quieran absolutamente. Por eso ahí está la palabra HTTP. Ya. A PIS. Tuán de sea. Incluso había un
cliente que se le hemos hecho un sistema de N8N para verificar la posición satelital más que
todo de sus drones. Es decir, en Argentina, por ejemplo, hay la mayor cantidad de sembradíos de
maíz que tienen ellos lo hacen con drones y los drones si o si tienen que salir a las 8 de la
mañana regar y volver a las 9 y 30 y estos web us lo hacen lo controlan hace el proceso de
estandarización con QG es y QG es lo manda un sistema satelital satelital ejecuta los rangos
y parámetros de eje cartesiano QG en la posición global lo envía a mi web hook y eso me da
los datos estadísticos, los datos de posesión y cuánto tiempo y cuánto autonomía tenía el
drone, etcétera, etcétera, etcétera, etcétera, o sea, en mundo dejado al otro, otro ambiente con
N8N y con web hooks. Ya. Luego están los form submissions. En este caso, para mí me sé para
ejecutar en este caso flujos cuando alguien quiere llegar a un plenar un formulario, por ejemplo,
eso es lo que vamos a ver bien. Ya. Por ahí les voy a llamar lo que es la parte de. Esas asistencias.
Por si caso antes de olvidarme recordarles que tienen que anotar su nombre a estrofinalizar
de la clase para que yo tenga la lista correspondiente de todos sus apellidos y demás para que yo envía
la embajada así que no se olviden de anotar sus nombres en el formulario antes de que termine
la clase. Eso por favor chicos, no se olviden. Ya seguiremos.
Está en el grupo de WhatsApp. Le enviado ahorita al último, o no le enviado,
le enviado a otro grupo a ver de un gusto. Ah, sí, está ahí. Antes que me digan que hay
el form. Listo. Ya. Me invito a los chicos. Ahorita los voy a hablar. Pues no quiero entrar
en mi WhatsApp. Un montón de gente. Ah, me está molestando. Ah, sí. Listo, listo, listo, listo.
De mancachito. Algún estaba. Ya, entonces, haremos lo siguiente. Ya. Os voy a explicar más,
pero quisiera avanzar un poquito porque si nos vamos a trazar y es ocho y treinta y veinte
meses vamos a terminar la clase. Ya, el último. Si nos vamos acá, por ejemplo, eh, hagamos
click acá en el primerito. Hagan click en aquí pueden entrar. Trigger manual. Ahí
coloquenlo acá. Hagan click nomás y listo. Les va a aparecer eso. Ya. Hasta ahí hemos
amado los espero. Ahora, esto por ejemplo, eh, vamos a trabajar con una guía. Mmm. Ya,
hagamos lo siguiente. Hagamos doble click. Ya, esto es para mí un trigger. ¿Cómo funciona
un trigger? ¿Cómo dice que ejecutar? Hagan click y listo. Ya se ha ejecutado. Se se dan
cuenta. Pues manual, o sea, con un click y funciona, pero obviamente va a depender mucho
que click. Tiene que hacer que o que. Ya. Pero vamos a entrar ahora a otro. Para eliminar
esto. Aquí está una basura, ¿Ven? Hagan click y listo. Vuelvan acá, vuelvan al símbolo
de más y vamos a hacer otro. Ya. One for submission haremos. Este de acá. One for
submission, hagan click. Les va a aparecer esto. Si lo cierran, les aparece esto. Ya.
Si quieren volver a abrir la pantalla que hemos visto el rato, hacen doble click y les va
a aparecer eso. Ya. Ahora, ¿Qué quiero que me entiendan? Y esto va a ser parte de su
tarea de hoy. Por si acaso. Así que trataremos de trabajarlo. Ya. Fíjense. Vuelvo a clicker.
Voy a repetir. Voy a borrar esto. Una vez más. Voy a repetir rápidamente. Vengo a más.
Vengo a este. O one for submission. A este. Perdón. Hacen click. Les va a aparecer esto.
Hay dos maneras de verlo. Dice que uno es de manera test. O sea, hay que testearlo como
está funcionando. Y otros mediante producción. Ya. Yo voy a manejar mediante tests. Y este
test, si nos damos cuenta si hago click acá. Fíjenos, no cambia mucho la URL que me bota.
¿Ven? No cambia mucho. Casi sigue siendo lo mismo. Solamente al último cambian unas
cositas. Pero vamos a primero testearlo. Ya. Ahora. No voy a colocar autenticación.
Todavía. Porque no quiero generar algún tipo de cosas que ahorita no estamos avanzando.
Así que lo voy a dejar como no. Ahora vamos a colocar fromTarget. En este caso. En el
from. Puedo colocar formulario de asistencia. Asistencia. Ya. Y dentro de acá. Yo puedo
trabajar en este caso describiendo. ¿Qué hace esto? Ya. Voy a colocar formulario. De asistencia.
De los estudiantes. De la embajada. Embajada. Visto. Ya está. Luego aquí puedo añadir
froms. Pero todavía no lo voy a hacer esto. Fíjense. Aquí lo voy a ejecutar. Y me va a
parecer esto. ¿Ven? Y ahora. Fíjense. Lo voy a minimizar un poquito para que se vea.
Ya. Ahí está mi formulario. Miren acá. Y aquí tengan en cuenta los siguientes chicos.
Mis get y mis post. Oh. La entrada y la salida. Los inputs o los outputs. Aquí en el lado izquierdo
siempre son los inputs. En el lado derecho siempre son los outputs. Si hago click submit.
Viren. Se registra. Alguien se ha registrado en esta fecha a esta hora, me dice. ¿Se dan cuenta?
Que hasta. Ya hemos creado nuestro primer hola mundo en n8n. Que es subir un sistema form.
Voy a cerrarlo. Voy a venir ahora. Voy a añadir algunos elementos. Por ejemplo,
voy a decir que añadir un elemento. Añadimos ahí un label. Por ejemplo, voy a decir como me pide.
What's your name? En este caso voy a colocar nombre completo.
Listo. ¿Qué tipo de texto es nombre? ¿Qué tipo de variable? Texto, ¿no? Texto voy a colocar.
Listo. Ahora. ¿Puedo colocarlo acá lo siguiente? Si se han dado cuenta con ustedes crean un formulario
en Google. Tienen que colocar ahí veces valores que sí o sí el cliente lo anote. No veo. O sea,
si tienen que notar. Porque hay unos que no envían su correo o se olvidan su apellido. Y si no colocamos
esa variable de que estamos obligándole a que el cliente coloque sus datos de nada vencerlo,
porque voy a perder clientes. ¿Qué hago? Entonces, vamos a añadir atributos. Y aquí dice. Valor
requerido. Hacemos click y vamos a clicar esto. Y ya está. Son atributos que hay que añadir.
Otro, por ejemplo, voy a dar otro elemento. Voy a añadir en este caso. A ver, vamos a colocar
profesión. No sé, me estoy inventando. Y vamos a colocar años. ¿Cuántos años tienes?
Listo. Venimos acá tipo numérico. Vamos a ver tipo nombre van a colocar. Y también que se ha
requerido. Listo. Añadimos otro. Podemos colocar ahí, por ejemplo, sexo. Masculino o femenino, digamos.
Ya. Ah, mejor podemos también colocar algún tipo de... Ah, esto colocamos. Un textarea que me
cuente, digamos. Cuéntame acerca de ti. Cuéntame de ti. Vamos a colocarlo. Ya. Aquí, si estamos
nosotros realizando quizás un... Ya se me fue la palabra ahorita. Para con su tarjenta, digamos.
Ya. Que me cuente, porque si me convence con sus palabras, este emocionado por un proyecto,
obviamente hay veces, aunque yo no le ve a la cara a un postulante, yo sé mediante su manera de
expresarse y hacer en voz o texto, sé que le gusta una persona. Por eso, así, generalmente,
nosotros evaluamos. Digamos que sea un requerimiento obligatorio. Listo. Eso también me olvida
obligatorio. Y por último, vamos a añadir otro que sea no sé, contraseño.
Y que sea tipo password. Ya. Aquí, este tipo password. Listo. Y listo. Hasta ahí. Ahora,
voy a ejecutarlo y debería de aparecer todos esos parámetros que ustedes han colocado. A ver,
yo voy a llamarme, voy a contratarme yo mismo, digamos. 28, cuéntame de ti. Soy apasionado
por... No, me encanta las ciencias espaciales.
Ustedes vayan colocando algo diferente y a su tienden que juntar a su word por
se caso. Y mi contraseño es 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 7. Listo. Lo subo y fíjense,
ya se me está actualizando esto con todo lo que lo estoy anotando. Listo. Entonces,
eso quiero que me hagan ahorita. Con esa opción. Ahora, por ejemplo, si vuelvo a ejecutarlo,
miren, van a ver. Me aparece acá abajo en N8N. Yo no quiero que aparezca porque el usuario
me hace que la ponen en N8N. No debes programarlo así. Pero puedo eliminarlo eso.
Puedo colocar aquí stop listening y aquí coloco adoption. Puedo colocar app n8 attribution.
Aquí, o cliquen esto y vuelvo a correrlo y ya no les va a aparecer eso. Miren.
Listo. Hasta ahí. Esto me sacan scream de esta cosa. Es un formulario. Y me van a sacar
el scream de la salida, del output que han hecho funcionar. Ya, así que aquí lo voy a añadir.
Mi primer workflow. Listo. Ahí lo añaden esto. Lo van a hacer bonito, pequeñito, no tan grande.
Y aquí también su salida. Yo su salida de acá. O sea, los cierro esto, stop listening y esto lo
pueden moverse y desear. Si no se ve muy bien, un poquito lo mueven. Ya ahí lo pueden sacar
o un scream de pantalla. Y esto me lo tienen que enviar si o si. Ya, hace un word.
Ya. Hasta ahí los espero chicos. Les doy dos, tres minutitos para que vayan haciendo.
Porque ahora vamos a hacer un VPS y van a ver qué diferencia con el VPS que voy a crearme.
Ya. Así ahí los espero. Les doy cinco minutitos mientras tanto.
Hola, hola, hola. Me escuchan chicos por si acaso. Se me ha perdido la conexión creo.
Se la escucha. Gracias, gracias. Gracias, gracias chicos. Porque en mi computadora me
estaba diciendo que perdí la conexión de red intentando extraversel. A ver.
Y esto, esto. Ya, les voy esperando ahí. Así que vayan adjuntando eso y lo van a enviar
hasta. Habíamos quedado, ¿no? Quería que se les enviar ahorita, pero habíamos quedado que lo van
a enviar hasta la una clase antes de la siguiente clase. Pero ya nos queda sábado así que normal.
Ya. Entonces, eso ya creo que no vamos a alcanzar más porque es 46. Voy a ver un cacho.
Quienes ya han llenado la la parte y tengo que sacar las asistencias también a lo que me dijeron.
Así que déjenme un cachito chico. ¿Cuáles voy a sacar? Asistencias ya.
21 menos 2 veces el mío son 19. Oye, entonces. Por si acaso vayan terminando de llenar lo que es el
form y tienen que haber 19 personas hoy día. Ya. Ya no os voy a pedir más llenar el formular y por
si acaso. Solamente es por hoy nomás. Ya. Así que a ver, de mancachito voy a ver esa parte.
Os voy a dar una tabra ahí, pero creo que con una clase extra en YouTube les voy a dar la tabra.
Ya. A ver. Vamos a generarme acá.
Mientras tanto, dentro de mi board voy a pegar sus asistencias.
De Anilse Lopez. Luego está.
Por si acaso va a haber clases donde los voy a sorprender con lista. Hoy día no. Ya.
Para ver si está o no está. Porque como no os estoy pidiendo activar sus cámaras porque
se les va a la guiar algunas cosas. Así que normal. Ya. Pero va a haber siempre una clase.
No os voy a sorprender. Así que. Yo tendré que tomarlo en cuenta. Ya. Justamente está nos dice
no. Ya. Super bien. Haremos lo siguiente. Creo que nos quedó unos 10 minutos. Así que vamos a
pasarles un sostenimiento. Ya. Vean van a descargarse para la siguiente clase. Ojo. Esto no está denso
programa. Pero sería bonito que aprendan. Ya. Así que vayan. Se habrán una nueva
pantalita y escriban en grog.com.
Ya. Ahí ingresan y les va a llevar esta parte.
Una vez que ingresen ahí van a ser lo siguiente.
Van a empezar. Ya. Se van a enlazar con su cuenta de Jimmy. La mía ya está enlazada. Pero me voy a
salir. Ya. Me voy a salir. Ya. Esto. Vayan haciendo hasta ahí.
A ustedes les va a pedir que si se entren por su correo electrónico.
Ya. Pero ahí les va a botar. Aquí tienen que clickearlo y listo. Una vez que estén dentro.
Super. Ahí lo dejan. Ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente. Van a escribir lo mismo en rock.
Descarga para windows o para el sistema operativo que ustedes están
trabajando.
Les voy a botar esta página. Les voy a pasar el link por.
Por. Ya. Ya. Ya los he mandado. Enlaz. Entren ahí.
Luego van a elegir acá. Y entonces van a elegir aquí les va a detectar.
Depende de su sistema interno de diferentes chips. Ya. Aquí por ejemplo ahí era.
Me de la M. Me detecta. Lo descarga y se lo descargará. Ya.
Por si acaso antes de antes de meter la pataca. Desactivan su antivirus aunque unos 10
minutos y a vas o 20 mil desactivan aunque un cachito para hacer esto. Porque si les detecta
nunca más les va a permitir por si acaso. Pero no desactivan antes. Ya. Esa parte siempre
se.
Y si jamás en la vida van a por. Ya pero descarguen y listo.
Ya. Ahí vamos a quedar chicos. Déeme un cachito. Algo más me pide la embajada que les avise.
A ver qué me está pidiendo para que les consulte. Son 19.
Listo. Déeme un cachito. Voy a sacar asistencias y.
Y eso que asistencias. No. Qué me piden más.
Ya.
Ya sé qué me pide. Déeme un cachito más y luego vamos a terminar la clase. Ya. Ya no sé.
En qué página estoy.
De me un cachito de un cachito.
A ver. Dios.
Listo.
Para la siguiente clase, por favor, eso instalado. No lo tienen que ejecutarlo por si acaso.
Solamente descarguenlo y descomprímelo. Nada más. No. No les voy a pedir otras cosas más.
Porque va a ser un lío. No lo no lo ejecuten nada más. Y lo han ejecutado de si ensalan.
No tienen que ejecutar eso.
Ya. Eso por si acaso es extra. No. No. No. No es el objetivo de la materia. Pero.
Es necesario que aprendan cómo funcionar un VPS. Así es que desean eso.
Ya. Luego chicos hasta ahí quedamos. Nos vemos el día sábado. Ah, por si acaso.
Esto también comentarles aprovechando. Lamentablemente. A veces yo tuve que la
es en la universidad hasta las seis seis y media. Así que si es que me atraso chicos,
aunque 10 minutos o 15 minutos. Voy a tratar de volar ya. Porque a veces no encuentro vehículos
y se me dificulta llegar a la oficina para darles clases. Así que si es que me atraso,
si es que me atraso los sábados netamente. Solamente sábados. Aunque 10 minutos.
15 o si llego a normal. Tolerancia. Igual os voy a recompensar 10 minutos más.
Listo chicos. Ahí quedamos con la clase de hoy. Que tengan un buen resto de jornada. Nos vemos la
siguiente clase. Chau chau. Ya se consisten.